the Russians put the first man on the
moon that steps away from nuclear war
There's No Going Back a three-way race
to Mars we're not going to come in
second place again today we take the
next step towards a self sustaining Mars
[Music]
colony they're looking for guys just
like us this job on Mars I could be
doing something that I never even
dreamed
of for the next 2 years of your life
Mars is your new home me out what's
happened something incredible this
asteroid it could change everything for
people back home there's more aridium in
the asteroid than has been mined in the
entire history of Earth I you we can
capture the most valuable known object
in our solar system North Korean CIA KGB
they're all running a piece of to this
pie is this about Justice or filling
your pockets what are you going to do
with all that money if you're dead I
always thought I'd go out BL of
Glory I'm going to get that Ro or die
trying we are powerless up here a
million miles from my family this isn't
what it was supposed to be people are
going to keep getting hurt well your
bank accounts grow bigger and
bigger building a new world for our
future you ready to make history always
my friend
I take me
out